Looks like we got competition i'll fix this
but i'm gonna need some help let's catch
some multiverse men just run it by us next
time you break the universe deal spider-man
you're not peter parker i am so
confused right now that spell
that you bought started pulling in visitors
from every universe the multiverse is real
they all die fighting there has to be another
way there isn't they're a danger to our universe
this is all my fault i can't save everyone
what's happening they're starting to
come through and i can't stop them
when you're thinking i'm about to do
something that could break the universe
i know you run it by us we need to send them back
you're not gonna take this away from me you're
flying out into the darkness to fight ghosts
what do you mean they all die fighting spider-man
i'm sorry kid yeah me too don't there
has to be another way there it is
i underestimated you peter do i know
you looks like we got competition
we started getting some visitors in their universe
they all die fighting spider-man i'm sorry kid
yeah me too
there don't to be another win there
it isn't what's happening they're
starting to come through i can't stop
him ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week where my life has
felt normal that was when you found out peter
that spell that you watched
it started pulling in visitors
from every universe what's happening they're
starting to come through and i can't stop him
hello peter do i know you you think
your fancy new suit's gonna save you
looks like we got competition
Welcome back everyone this will be my new
spider-man no way home trailer video and
footage breakdown there's a whole bunch of new
tv spots with a ton of new scenes and easter eggs
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos this is just the
beginning there's going to be a bunch of really
cool stuff happening hawkeye episodes also start
this week and i'll be doing videos for all those
episodes but the first new scene is of spider-man
and doctor octopus during the bridge fight a
lot of new bridge fight scenes it begins when he
starts thrashing spider-man around and it's right
after he says hello peter who responds do i know
you i don't even know who you are because remember
tom holland's mcu spider-man has never seen any
version of doctor octopus before not an mcu doctor
octopus and certainly not the doctor octopus from
the tobey maguire spider-man movie universe
and at this point doctor octopus just assumes
that he's fighting tobey maguire's spider-man he
still thinks that he's in his original universe
because then he says you think your fancy new
suits are going to stop me just talking about
the iron spider suit like he still thinks that
it's tobey maguire underneath the mask that's
why later when spider-man takes the mask off he
says wait a minute you're not peter parker which
spider-man reacts to by saying i am so confused
right now because he has no idea what's going on
with the multiverse the spider verse of it all you
notice that doctor octopus still has the tentacle
spike weapon from spider-man 2 because remember
this is meant to be him from the second after he
went down into the river at the end of spider-man
2 so it's as if no time has passed for him
at all even though after he died time continued
to pass in tobey maguire's spider-man universe
so like tobey maguire's spider-man will look
like he's much older when we see him in the
movie but this doctor octopus looks the exact
same age as when he went down in the river
it's all because of the way spider-man messes up
doctor strange's spell and causes reality to warp
in the multiverse so you have different time
periods in different parts of the multiverse
mixing and matching with each other so that's how
you have both green goblin and doctor octopus who
died at different points in the timeline of the
tope maguire spider-man movies now co-existing
in the same time period of the mcu but then right
after he starts joking about his fancy new suit
not being able to stop him he throws spider-man
who responds by using the iron spider suit legs to
rip his way through the metal and doctor octopus
kind of has this funny reply chagrin saying looks
like we have some competition talking to his arms
like they're competing to see who has the most
arms if it wasn't clear for those of you that are
asking doctor octopus's arms are technically way
stronger than the iron spider arms like he could
rip them apart but i do like the theory here that
spider-man is actually able to use the iron spider
nanites in a really clever way to immobilize
doctor octopus's arms so when they start covering
him and it looks like doctor octopus has iron man
built octopus arms it might actually be spider-man
using the iron spider nanites to immobilize his
arms like what if spider-man is still technically
in control the nanites in what they're doing when
this is happening because they have to get
doctor octopus in that basement prison of
the sanctum somehow and while this is a cool iron
man easter egg reference here in all the trailers
in this new version of the electro scene where
he's yelling at spider-man you're not going to
take this away from me just referencing doctor
strange's orders to capture them and send them
back to their original universes in time periods
effectively a death sentence but you zoom in
enhanced and what do you see here it's iron man's
arc reactor from iron man 2 the one that he built
using the new element that he created at the end
of the movie now here's the thing iron man built
many more advanced arc reactors the avengers end
game arc reactor for the mark 85 armor being his
final one but the one from iron man 2 is still
based on an infinity stone remember he used howard
stark's research on the tesseract to perfect a
new element so the element is based on an infinity
stone so he's basically been powering himself with
infinity stone energy this whole time since then
in the mcu it's a good way of explaining how iron
man has been so op when he doesn't have the same
level of biological powers as people like thor
but no idea how electro manages to steal this
or where he stole it from probably some stark
industries museum exhibit or a lab somewhere
post all your theories in the comments below about
where you think that he got this arc reactor from
the reason why electro would be using an arc
reactor in the first place would just be to
keep himself at maximum power output for much
longer then there's more new footage of spider-man
and doctor octopus quipping about being super
confused and when they're in the sanctum later
because it seems like doctor octopus is actually
the one to really explain everything to him after
they get in the prison beneath the sanctum like at
a certain point doctor strange yells at him about
them getting visitors from other universes things
bleeding over but it sounds like he doesn't really
understand what's happening until he crosses paths
with doctor octopus also really funny extra detail
you may have noticed inside the basement where
they're keeping doctor octopus you notice all
around the basement here there's just tons of
junk that it seems like doctor strange and wong
are storing here in the sanctum there's even a
fully complete model train set all set up in the
background i'm gonna go ahead and guess and say
that that's wong's model train set after the wong
versus abomination fight scene his character got
like 10 times more interesting like is he gambling
for money does he need more sandwich money is
that why he's doing this now we also know that
he loves to drink and do karaoke there's just so
many new questions that we have about wong now
and right now in spider-man no way home it looks
like he's packing up to head to warmer climate
like he's going to carmartas to just hang out
because of what's happening in the sanctum with
snow covering everything which is also still
a huge unanswered question like what is going
on in the sanctum when this is all happening
i know there are all kinds of crazy theories
about this not being the real doctor strange like
somebody pretending to be doctor strange but then
we also get a brand new funny scene with j jonah
jameson where he calls the lizard a dinosaur like
is that a dinosaur the clip is kind of janky and
potato quality but the scenes are really funny
who are those guys huh
what's going on call me back
is real
dinosaur the scene of happy there yelling at
peter's answering machine it's just a callback
to spider-man homecoming when they just spent all
that time trying to call each other and happy just
being really pissed off about having to take time
to talk to spider-man on the phone because he felt
like he was a glorified babysitter oh how times
have changed this time he's yelling at him about
the sinister six visitors as doctor strange calls
them we started getting some visitors there's
another new scene of mj and spider-man while
they're still in the basement of the sanctum
going full scooby-doo where she starts yelling
at him for not telling her about doctor strange's
spell like she says next time you're thinking
about doing something that's gonna break the
universe maybe you run it by us first so what
that tells us is that the way spider-man messes
with doctor strange's spell causing all this havoc
successfully allows mj nedleys to remember him and
their time together otherwise the movie would stop
short after the spell like he'd have to run around
and then re-explain his entire backstory to mj and
ned lee so that they could do the scooby-doo stuff
there's a brand new scene of spider-man versus
the sandman he's got him with his giant hand
here then there's another new sandman scene of him
who's reaching out to the frame here for those of
you asking what happened to him because doctor
strange and doctor octopus both imply that all
the villains died during fights with spider-man in
their original universes but during spider-man 3 a
lot of you remember the last time we saw sandman
he was very much alive at the end of that movie i
believe during spider-man no way home they'll just
cover the rest of those sinister six characters
story lines and sandman for instance probably died
in some later fight with tobey maguire spider-man
after the events of spider-man 3. the other big
new scene in here is a longer version of the train
fight scene between spider-man and doctor strange
after he's joined doctor strange's magic box and
they've entered what looks like the mere dimension
where everything in new york city looks like it's
folded in on itself it's a slightly different
version of what they did during the first doctor
strange movie when they were running around the
warped new york city landscape it is basically
doctor strange using the same trick against
spider-man that kaiselius was using against
doctor strange trying to trap him to keep him from
running away because doctor strange is trying to
trap spider-man to get the box back there's also
another scene with a much better look at the new
york city post newspaper at the beginning of
the trailer about his spider minions you can
clearly see they parodied mj and ned leeds like
he's manipulating them as if they are literally
his minions probably because everybody in new york
city just sees them walking around with peter all
the time the reason why it's not a daily bugle
newspaper is because in the mcu the daily bugle
in present day isn't a newspaper anymore it's
evolved into this big tv online news network
so there's no print publishing arm of the daily
bugle anymore it's all video blogs radio podcasts
like you can see the dla bugle news trucks around
jay jonah jameson in all these scenes here outside
but if you spotted any other easter eggs in this
new footage that i didn't talk about during the
video just write them below in the comments we'll
get more trailers as we get closer to the movie
coming out so we'll get some more clues about
what's going on with the spider-verse of it all
at the rate they're going with any
luck we'll also see some more weird
scenes where it looks like they're trying to
manipulate footage to remove other versions
of spider-man like that weird andrew garfield
lizard scene he moves right there coincidence
i think not big reminder too this week hawkeye
episode 1 and episode 2 are releasing on wednesday
so my videos for that will post that day i'll
be doing videos for all the episodes make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss that and everyone click here for my
full spider-man no way home trailer video and that
weird andrew garfield scene and click here for my
venom let there be carnage alternate post-credit
scene deleted scenes and alternate ending
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!